this video is made possible by nord VPN
get the nord VPN holiday bill
nord VPN comm forward slash visual
politic or use the coupon code visual
politic you'll get a three year plan
with 81% off plus two amazing gifts four
extra months of nord pass password
manager which is worth a hundred and
ninety four dollars and 61 cents he
isn't well known leader and he doesn't
run a state so much as a relatively
small country and officially he isn't
even that country's top leader despite
all this on june the second 2019 the new
york times published a report declaring
Mohammed bin Zayed as the most powerful
political leader in the arab world
he even ranks above the new de facto
Saudi Arabian leader Mohammed bin Salman
of whom we've already spoken about here
on visual politic of some links to those
videos in the description after their
New York Times report was published we
asked ourselves a few questions
who exactly is Mohammed bin Zayed what
are his keys to power is he really the
most powerful Arabic political leader in
the world well listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
Mohammed bin Zayed is the Crown Prince
of Abu Dhabi the richest and most
powerful emirate of the United Arab
Emirates
here's also the deputy supreme commander
of the Emirates Armed Forces and
presidents of the Abu Dhabi Executive
Council that is the presidents of the
Abu Dhabi government's quite a feat
and it's his political abilities along
with the poor health of his older
brother Sheikh Khalifa bin Zayed that
have made him happy
Derby's de facto leader and by extension
the leader of all the United Arab
Emirates as you may know the United Arab
Emirates is a small country located in
the Persian Gulf and similar in size to
Panama or South Carolina we're talking
about a country made up of seven
different emirates out of which the two
best known by far are Abu Dhabi and
Dubai in fact even though this country
is made up of seven emirates the truth
is that at the political level abu dhabi
is by far the most important emirate
why what we're gonna see that later in
this video but we can already give you
quite a weighty reason Abu Dhabi holds
more than 90 percent of all the Arab
Emirates all reserves but for now let's
go back to Mohammed bin Zayed great
honor to have Sheikh Muhammad with us
today a man that I've known for special
for a special person highly respected
and loves his country I can tell you
that loves his country
[Music]
this character was born in 1961 and was
the third son of Sheikh Zayed bin Sultan
the first president of the United Arab
Emirates from a young age he focused his
career on the army where he became an
Air Force pilot and the Armed Forces is
where he also started his political
career in 1991 just after Saddam Hussein
initiated Iraq's invasion of Kuwait the
UN emirati air forces commander landed
in Washington with a mission to buy all
possible military equipment Hellfire
missiles Apache helicopters f-16 planes
they wanted the full package from that
moment on Mohammed bin Zayed became one
of Washington's closest allies not only
within the Arab countries but on the
entire planet because we're talking
about a political leader who over the
years has become one of the icons of
reform and openness in the Arab world
under his management Abu Dhabi has taken
pioneering steps both in Dubai's
economic and civil matters and on some
issues they went even further perhaps
the best proof of this is the Pope's own
visit to the Emirates which we recently
covered here on visual politic however
even though he was leading a reform
program that has made the Emirates
perhaps the most open and prosperous
country in the Arab world Mohammed bin
Zayed also fiercely supports an idea
that can sounds at the very least
controversial and that's that the Arab
world is not ready for democracy
according to bin zayed openness in the
Arab world can only come about to those
nations led by authoritarian regimes
promoting democracy would only feed
fundamentalist groups that would end up
winning the elections it's an idea that
is actively defended and as
significantly shaped the Emirates
external relations in recent years but
having said this I think we now have to
turn to the key question of this video
where does this character fit in and how
much power does he really have well as
examined the three main areas that form
the foundation of his power
[Music]
the power of the portfolio I don't think
anyone will find it strange if I say
that money has always been one of the
most important elements in power
well if Arab countries have been famous
for anything it has been their
conspicuous consumption they are no
strangers to spending indecent amounts
of money on all kinds of things whims or
projects that lead nowhere well in this
case besides spending a lot of money on
all kinds of public projects what
Emirates have also done has been to save
and invest a good part of their money
all over the world
it got to the point that today Mohammed
bin Zayed has one of the fullest
portfolios we can imagine but the
question becomes exactly how much money
do the Emirates and Abu Dhabi have in
their sovereign wealth fund how much are
we really talking about here for those
who don't know a sovereign fund is an
investment fund that a government
creates to invest at savings and assets
in order to generate profitability
basically it's just like any savers
investment fund
well according to the latest estimates
the United Arab Emirates sovereign funds
have accumulated investments worth more
than 1.3 trillion dollars out of this
amounts just over 900 billion dollars
are concentrated in Abu Dhabi's two main
sovereign wealth funds having Darby's
investment authority controls almost 700
billion making it the third largest
sovereign wealth fund in the world and
MOBA Dollaz funds has just over 220
billion u.s. dollars we're talking about
an absolute fortune here more than 900
billion dollars saved by the emirate of
Abu Dhabi and invested throughout the
world in stocks debt buildings highways
ports airports banks hospitals hotels
factories mines even ice-cream parlors
in really everything and that explains
why you see news stories like these Abu
Dhabi pays a Bertie's 495 million
dollars for 20% of its Chilean
subsidiary Abu Dhabi Investment
Authority to invest 50 billion dollars
into India one of the largest sovereign
funds in the world the Abu Dhabi
Investment Authority will pour 50
billion dollars into India especially
into infrastructure and food processing
capacity
[Music]
but let's be careful here because power
doesn't only consist of having a full
portfolio but also of controlling assets
and companies of all kinds throughout
the entire worlds and to have a cash
flow that is very very coveted by most
governments who doesn't want a few
billion invested in their country I mean
it's just pure diplomacy
[Music]
in any case there's a detail that we
can't skip you see the emirate of Abu
Dhabi only has a population of 2.7
million people out of which just over
half a million have Emirati nationality
that is the emirate of Abu Dhabi's
savings alone in its two main sovereign
firms announced more than three hundred
and forty thousand dollars per
inhabitant and more than 1.6 million per
citizen of Abu Dhabi with a Marathi
nationality they've been saving since
1976 and even though they're sitting on
such a large amount of money they take
the fact that the government doesn't
have a public deficit very seriously Abu
Dhabi to see a budget surplus in 2018
thanks to public consolidation efforts
but that is only only due to Mohammed
bin Zayed power
you
[Music]
the power of force this is perhaps the
Emirates least known aspect but in
recent years this small country has
earned itself the nickname little Sparta
the United Arab Emirates Army is very
small it has just over 60,000 soldiers
but in the last two decades under
Mohammed bin Zayed commands along with a
lot of experts among whom is the former
US Secretary of Defense Jim mattis this
army has been restructured around one
simple idea to be a small that very
well-equipped agile and well-trained
army to achieve this the Emirates
military budget exceeds 20 billion
dollars every year this has allowed them
to buy all kinds of foreign equipment 70
f-16s updated with the latest technology
more than 70 mirages 30 Apaches 19
Chinooks more than 400 Leclerc tanks 76
scorpions thousands of armored vehicles
of all kinds dozens of drones the
Patriot missile system they even bought
the crown jewel the fat missile system
one of the most modern systems in the
United States indeed it is the same one
that the US has deployed in South Korea
creating a huge confrontation with China
and this is just the beginning because
now they're looking at the f-35 in fact
after Saudi Arabia it's the second
largest buyer of technology and military
equipments from the United States but if
the Arab armies have traditionally been
known for something it has been for
spending a lot of money on equipments
and when the time comes not really
taking advantage of it that's why
another of Mohammed bin Zayed priorities
has been to ensure that the Emirati army
is well-trained Saudi think they went
about it
[Music]
[Applause]
well in addition to paying for all kinds
of training courses abroad the MRRT army
has committed itself to going into
combat in the last few years especially
hand-in-hand with the United States
itself since 2003 the emirate has
deployed elite troops in Afghanistan
sent troops to Somalia to combat piracy
and after the United States it is the
country that has carried out the most
air missions against the Islamic state
always hand in hand with the US and not
only that they have also recently
intervened on their own in Libya in
northern Sinai in Egypt and massively in
Yemen of course they've also had lots of
experts from around the world so much so
that some units are even under the
command of foreign officers in other
words they have contracted their own
officers this is the case for example of
general - Maher a former lieutenant
colonel of the United States Army who is
now in command of the Emirati helicopter
division North Australian Mike hen's
Maher shoot runs the presidential guard
the result is that today the Emirati
army is not only considered one of the
best equipped armies but also one of the
best trains throughout the region
they're catching up with Israel a
country which they're currently buying
technology from and that's not all in
another move to gain autonomy the
emirati authorities of reinstate of the
mandatory military service and have
invested a lot of money to develop a
full national weapons industry a
military industry all of its own of
course it's being done hand in hands
with large multinationals and their
technology and the truth is that it's
working
[Music]
there are currently almost 200 emirati
defense companies manufacturing all
kinds of equipments armored vehicles
guided missiles drones light airplanes
all manufactured in the Emirates now
they are even trying to develop their
own propeller bomber to operate at low
altitude on counterinsurgency missions
but wait there's more the emirate has
opens military bases in places like
Yemen Eritrea and Somalia lands which is
unprecedented and has prepared to
operate alongside mercenary armies elite
mercenaries led by Eric Prince the
founder and owner of the Blackwater
Company which complements the
capabilities of their own army Emirates
secretly sends Colombian mercenaries to
Yemen fight in short this is the change
that is taking place in the army and it
has earned them the nickname little
Sparta all by the hand of our central
character but this isn't his only weapon
[Music]
geostrategy
enforce with proven reserves of more
than 97 billion barrels the emirate says
the seventh-largest conventional oil
reserve on the planet under its own
subsoil they are currently producing
about 3 million barrels per day and
expect to reach 4 million by 2020 and 5
million by 2030 this is an enormous
amount of oil so with all that oil and
all the money we've seen Mohammed bin
Zayed has launched a diplomatic career
across the planet that has multiplied
this small country's international
influence in recent years India
Indonesia Ethiopia and of course the
United States his relations with the
Trump administration of the middle the
truth is that with such assets under
their belts no door remains closed and
if we add to all of this the fact that
the Emirates has become an important
financial commercial logistical and even
tourist center in the last two decades
and that this man Mohammed bin Zayed is
practically leading everything it
doesn't seem crazy to stage that today
he is the most powerful Arab political
leader in the world of course being the
most powerful Arab doesn't mean it's all
smooth sailing not at all Qatar's
blockade has been a resounding failure
but that is something that we covered in
a previous video just before we end the
video today this video is made possible
by nord VPN if you're buying things
online and using a public Wi-Fi spot
think you know coffee shops airports
things like that you really should be
using a VPN and that's where Nord VPN
comes in now we know it's tempting not
to bother and just kind of just hope for
the best you know hopefully this time
someone won't steal my data but those
stories you read online about people
having their data stolen their identity
stolen things like that they really do
happen and you don't want to make it
easy for people to do that to you
whenever I'm browsing on public Wi-Fi I
just have a VPN or running in the
background so I don't have to worry
about anyone stealing my data is just a
nice peace of mind
but it's not just about security you can
also use it to change the country that
you appear to be in so you can get
content that might normally only
available in specific geographic
locations Nord VPN is super fast so
watching video is a breeze there's no
lag whatsoever
if you've used VPNs in the past and
thought they were really slow on No More
with an awed VPN and you can use it on
all of your devices very easily Android
Chrome Windows Linux all of those are
supported and you can use it on six
different devices with one account also
there's no logs kept online companies
based in you or us Nord VPN over in
Panama say enough to keep logs at all
obviously great for your privacy indeed
they are the only VPN to get a perfect
score from PC Mag now you might have
heard about the Nord breach in the news
recently but it's important to point out
that no user information was exposed in
this breach because Nord VPN doesn't
keep any logs on its servers because it
doesn't keep any logs at all it's based
out of Panama so it doesn't have to
however Nord VPN are still moving to a
100% own server model unlike most other
VPNs they are also improving other
aspects of their security
so start protecting your internet
experience today and get the Nord VPN
holiday deal at North VPN con forward
slash visual politic or use the coupon
visual politic you'll get a three year
plan with 81% off plus two amazing gifts
that would be four extra months for free
than the Nord pass password manager app
worth together 194 dollars and 61 cents
and thank you for watching and if you
want to learn more about politics and
hear even more of my lovely voice you
can join us at reconsider media we have
a podcast at reconsider mediacom slash
podcast see you there
[Music]